welcome back to age 20 special
relativity in the last section we
discussed that
moving clocks
tick differently than those which are at
rest
and here i would like to discuss a
real-life example of this
the muon the muon is an elementary
particle very similar to the electron
its mass is about 200 times as heavy
um the mune was discovered in the 1930s
by anderson and nedermeier at caltech
and
it it's really one of my favorite
particles because you can they're
abundant they there's many of them in
cosmic ear showers
you can study them you can study their
lifetime you can even calculate their
lifetime on a on a piece of piece of
paper
so what anderson and nedermeyer did is
they just basically you know went
outside and discovered a particle which
comes from the sky
and
so they studied cosmic radiation moons
are produced in cosmic air showers and
we look at one of those a little later
basically proton sits the upper
atmosphere and
in a shower of various particles neurons
are being produced
and then those neurons are not stable
particles but they are stable enough to
reach us
on average if you hold out your hand
right now
about one neuron
travels through your hand every second
how does how is this possible so if you
look at this muon give you a little bit
of particle physics explanation here
again the muon is not a stable particle
that decay the decay via the weak
interaction for those who are interested
uh this is the final diagram for this
decay the muon couples to the w
and as a result of the decay you find an
electron an anti-electron neutrino and a
neuron
the lifetime
is about 2.2 microseconds
2.2 times 10 to the minus 6 seconds
and i just taught 8701 which is
introductory class into particle and
nuclear physics and the students
calculated the lifetime of a muon in
that class so you can calculate this and
you need a few tools but it's not that
hard after all
the average velocity of the neurons when
they're being produced
is close to the speed of light or 0.998
times the speed of light and if you do a
classical calculation and you want to
figure out how long do the muons on
average live
fly you find that this is about 660
meters
now they are produced in the upper
atmosphere and nevertheless we can find
them
down here on the earth so something is
not quite right
what is not quite right you can already
assume is that the clock in the muon
uh as observed by us
uh ticks much much slower than
this
then for the muon at rest and so the
lifetime of the mural of 2.2
microseconds is basically extended
um if you calculate this this average
velocity we find
a gamma factor of 15 using the equations
we this you know for time dilation you
just simply multiply 15 times 2.2
microseconds and you find that neurons
indeed reach our hand
on the surface of earth
all right this is a really fun example
again you can study uh those cosmic air
showers with moons um and and learn
about the neurons in very simple
experiments
this picture here shows you one of those
air shower formations so the story is a
little bit more complex as i explained
this is a spectacular air shower or a
picture of one where you have an
important coming in with an energy of 10
to the 15 electron volt
and so even at slower lower energies
showers look like the one here
you produce
in collision with
the atmosphere
many many particles pions protons
additional protons neutrons and ions
again and those pions then they decay
into neurons and this all happens
in the upper atmosphere but also in some
cases further down
so here we have seen now
an example which you can actually see
and observe in nature where particles
travel with high speed and there is
relativistic effects we can measure and
observe
you